I've been trying to think about a story
of Sodom and Gomorrah in relationship to
modern sexual confusion so this is what
I see happening on the social justice
front let's say on the one hand since
the 1960's and probably has a
consequence of the birth control pill
but other factors as well there's been
tremendous stress placed on sexual
liberation and so there's this idea that
I think is associated in large part
right now with the radical left of total
sexual freedom but at the same time
there's increasing emphasis from exactly
the same sources on restricting sexual
interaction so you see this in the
campuses for example where increasingly
particularly heterosexual contact is
regulated by a doctrine that says you
have to get spoken permission for every
move in the mating process and so you
see and I know I'm not expressing myself
very well but there seems to be in our
current culture there seems to be
massive sexual confusion it's it's some
weird combination of extreme libertinism
and extreme authoritarianism part of
what's happening happening and is that
sex impulse of sexual gratification
trumps everything it's something like
that I mean I know there's more to
what's going on and saw them than that
but there's certainly that and so well
I'm trying to figure out what to say
about that tonight because well there's
there's a lesson in there the lesson is
something like don't let sexuality
don't let impulse and sexuality get the
upper hand it's something like that or
all hell will break loose which I
actually happen to agree with so one of
the things that we haven't been able to
talk about in our culture I think is
let's take the idea of the phenomenon of
AIDS like AIDS mutated to take advantage
of promiscuous sexuality and that's just
nothing you never hear that publicized
you know people had associated AIDS with
homosexuality and there was a reason for
because it's much more easily
transmitted as a consequence of
homosexual sex than heterosexual sex
because the anus is a much more delicate
to geological structure it's not as
robust and it can be eaten much more
easily damaged and and and with with
disease resulting as a consequence but
it isn't only the matter of sexual
action that's the issue it's also the
fact that promiscuity provided the
evolutionary platform for the AIDS virus
to mutate into a very into the form that
it finally took and it was only through
the skin by the skin of our teeth that
we escaped a totalizing plague you know
had that emerged a hundred years ago god
only knows how many people would have
died
AIDS was unbelievably fatal so I know
that's a mishmash of ideas and I'm not
exactly sure how to see my way clear
through it but there is a clear warning
in that story about about something
about size to do it with with a sexual
iniquity as in in the Bible that
sexuality has to two poles that define
it and it's pretty clear one one side is
reproduction and the other side is we
could let's say recreation okay so so
those are the two poles of sexuality in
a normal world so it's not just for
reproduction and it's not just for
recreation it's both like that was the
idea I mean it's a natural idea now if
you if there's a balance there and you
know that should be had if you lose this
balance and it becomes just about
reproduction that's a problem if it
becomes just about recreation that's
another problem you know okay it's not
that complicated really but it's so
politically incorrect to talk about
these things even though they're obvious
well that nobody cares to talk about it
the thing is is that the most difficult
things to talk about are the things that
are obvious because when they're obvious
you don't have to talk about them and so
then when people start to question the
obvious you don't know what to say it's
like just so for example we would
you know I I'm thinking about the slut
walks you know and so women go out and
they dress very provocatively and and
they go out and manifest their right to
be as provocative as they possibly can
be without being interfered with and I
have some sympathy for that perspective
because it seems to me appropriate for
women to be the final arbiters in sexual
contact but on the other hand it also
it's that whole exercise is blind to the
fact that clothing for example has
communicative intent and that people
broadcast their invitation to sexual
congress in a million ways subtle and
not-so-subtle and you can't just say I
have the right to broadcast myself in
any manner possible and be completely
beat what completely immune from the
consequences there's something wrong
with that and with regards to basic
sexual morality you know I've read
things about like slut-shaming is that
the more radical feminist types for
example claim that women shouldn't be
held responsible for their sexual
behavior in some sense it shouldn't be
held against them how many men they've
slept with etc but then I think well you
never recommend to someone that they lay
down naked on the on the side of the
street with their legs spread and invite
anybody who walks by to partake of the
opportunity
everyone would regard that as
inappropriate I think without question
and so what that indicates is that some
degree of sexual propriety is both
normative and ethical and then of course
you can start asking yourself about what
that degree of social sexual propriety
should be and it does have something to
do with getting the balance between
reproduction and recreation right okay
but the thing even in the Bible there's
there's the two aspects some stories are
about just this aspect and there are the
most strange stories in the Bible for
example the story of Tamar is
those so I don't know if you're familiar
with that story enough it's in that it's
it's intercut with the story of Joseph
okay in Egypt and it's essentially it
says that Judah has children with some
woman and I think it's a stranger it
doesn't necessarily say so but it seems
like that's what it is
and then the sons die off and then
there's this woman called Tamar and she
disguises herself as a prostitute great
and she has a kid with Judah himself so
all the symbols have heard that surety
elements of his clothing
yeah demonstrate as as a bride yes
essentially she wants to indicate later
that he's the one who slept with her
yeah yeah yeah
so that story is about then except the
need for the recreative part of
sexuality it's all about that symbolism
it's all about the seat it's all about
incest it's all about that and the idea
is it's to raise the dead okay it's not
clear in the story but if you understand
the imagery that's what it's about it's
about regressing back to an error that
was made okay and raising the dead so I
don't want to get into it but okay just
the idea that in the Bible there's folks
- there's reproduction and there's
recreation and that a recreation is
renewal does the original sexuality is
about renewal - but that aspect of the
symbolism is is pretty I want to say
obscure because it's actually right
there if you can see it but it's it's
strange I'll say it like that
it's a strange okay okay so now another
element of this might be the fact that
in modern identity politics sexual
choice is a canonical identifier and
that also seems to me to be something
wrong about that like one of the things
I've seen happening in Toronto I'm sure
it's the same in Montreal is that
I'm going to do this awkwardly I'm going
to put this awkwardly because I haven't
been able to sort through it properly
Pride Week Pride Day has turned into
Pride Week and that's turned into Pride
Month and I think that seems to me to be
pushing against some kind of limit
because the first question that I have
is like I was reading this book the
other day by a friend of mine from
Ottawa who's a gay conservative and he
said he had a lot harder time coming out
as a conservative than he had as coming
out as gay and he talked about the
degree to which homosexuals were
persecuted in Canada before say the
1980s and it's quite it makes quite
harsh reading let's say and so and so
fair enough to the to the civil rights
movement let's say it that has brought
homosexuality into the norm or that into
the mainstream maybe that's one way of
thinking about it but that conversation
still has a tremendous amount of
development that's necessary because I
don't understand exactly it isn't
obvious to me what integration into the
mainstream precisely means because a lot
there's been a lot of talk so far about
respecting the rights of gay people but
very little talk about what the
accompanying responsibilities might be
that actually seems to me to be a
problem and I mean I just had a letter
from from gay guy who is being wrestling
with this because he's not sure how to
be gay and to be ethical at the same
time you know because he sees part of
normative behavior as taking wife and
having children and not and can see the
value in that but that's certainly not
the direction of his proclivity and so
he wrote wrote to me asking me what he
should do and you know I don't have an
answer for that I don't know what the
answer to that is but I know that it
might be something that would be worth
talking about and then it's part of this
current confusion about sexual identity
and sexual pleasure and and
well even gender identity for that
matter so alright so your idea was well
the balance between recreation and
reproduction had gone was completely
absent in Sodom it was all recreation it
was all instant gratification and
impulse there and that's why it's put in
contest with the Abraham bit because
it's the same angels in that case he
says you'll have a son this time next
year so it's the reproduction part is
there but when he gets to the bottom
it's not there anymore it's only the
recreation part okay yeah so they're
opposed they're meant to be contested
those two sort actually in the story of
Abraham it's pretty clear he goes um I
don't know if this will make sense
because it in when the angels come it
says um he watched it their feet and
then he beats them okay that's actually
the recreation and reproduction part
that's not a sense of sexuality but it's
in terms of meaning the renewal the
washing of the feet is the recreation
part the renewals or restarting and the
feeding is the reproduction part not not
in sexual way but when you feed
something food and each of the integral
integrates it correctly that's like our
reproduction of your identity you're
you're staying yourself you're
reproducing yourself so when you eat
food that's what you're doing not like I
said not in a sexual way but it has
exactly the same meaning if you eat
something that you can integrate
correctly you're like reproducing your
pattern it's like the correct version of
yourself commitment the other side the
washing is that like is that little
flood yeah it's a mini flood right it
also isn't accessible right it's a
controlled one you're washing the dust
off your the roads dust off your faith
it means that you're you're passing from
one mode of being into another because
you're you're cleaning off the debris of
the past it's something like that and
then you're it's about renewal next
okay so you have to see that when when
Matthews talking about the idea of
recreation you have to understand that
recreation and rest are basically the
same thing right that's basically have
the same meaning it's sleeping resting
recreation are all things that bring you
into renewal okay all right you're dying
you're dying that's what dying is it's
this passing into another state letting
something else have a chance
that's what dying is it's I mean